you
live from Los Angeles the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
the 65th Annual Academy
Roxy LeBlanc revlon the most
unforgettable women in the world where
revlon lee with regular relaxed and
loose their jeans lee is the rarest
things the heartbeat of america
chevrolet and your local Chevy dealer
and coca-cola always the real thing
always coca-cola it's Twilight in
California where movie fans have been
gathering since early morning outside
the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion you're
invited to share in the film community's
big night as the stars arrived nominated
for Best Supporting Actress for
enchanted April the distinguished joan
flower ride morgan freeman former Oscar
winner and media mogul husband Jane
Fonda and Ted Turner
Susan Sarandon and Tim Robbins nominees
for Oscars his best actor and Best
Supporting Actress Stephen ray and
miranda Richardson previous nominee for
Cross Creek and a presenter this evening
alfre woodard Academy award-winning
actress and presenter tonight Kathy
Bates
oscar-winner up tonight for Best Actor
in alchemax Denzel Washington nominated
for three Oscars tonight a Hollywood
favorite Clint Eastwood first-time
nominee for My Cousin Vinny Marisa Tomei
five-time Oscar nominee and a presenter
tonight Glenn Close
Best Actress nominee for her remarkable
performance in Howards End Emma Thompson
Richard Gere and Cindy Crawford
the man who marches to his own drummer
and nominated tonight Jack Nicholson
star of Basic Instinct and one of the
industry's hottest actresses Sharon
Stone the crowd who wanted to see the
stars sure got their wish tonight a fine
actor who's a presenter this evening and
a welcome addition to any Oscar show
Raul Julia from the accounting firm of
Christ Waterhouse who tabulate the
balloting and guarantee the secrecy and
the integrity of the results mr. Frank
Johnson and mr. Dan Lyle two-time Oscar
winner as Best Actress in a presenter
Jodie Foster presenting a special award
tonight she's been honored by the
Academy three times the timeless Sophia
Loren
star big and in a league of their own
a stunning star in a league of her own
its Geena Davis
world-famous tenor who will be
performing one of the nominated songs
Placido Domingo Academy Award winner and
member of a distinguished Hollywood
family Angelica Houston Best Actor
nominee for his brilliant work in
Chaplin Robert Downey jr. nominated
eight times tonight will hopefully be a
great night for Al Pacino and that's
Richard Harrison answer Kel